look at this little
it's too late or oh hold on is it a
stool for
a penis maybe
it's a sex stool
it's a bit small
is it for adults it's for elevation it's
you get good angles with this thing you
stand on it i don't know that that was
made for that
yeah is that mead jacob you betcha i
didn't want to drink rose for another
podcast i felt like i would look white
again i whited
yeah it's a bit problematic we should be
talking about that you want me to i
could wipe my mind
skin revered
like ill
oh you look great
well i was saying this beforehand oh
wait it should be
hello the show has begun let me just
start it so then we can just tangent our
way to wherever we want hi everyone
welcome to another episode of idiots and
abroad i'm alana i'm joined by my
friends john jacob and rahul who are
people from
all different places in the world
currently in different places in the
world uh john where are you right now
i am in kansas city but i have just
returned from new orleans
nice
yeah
and we're all in city of sin
in vancouver i'm in vancouver yeah
canada and jacob and i are in l.a
i'm la i just got back from work nice
but i did visit vancouver um john what
were you in your new orleans for
i was in new
uh
orleans
i am a world traveler i'm a
not a rubber [ __ ] that's when they
travel by cars uh a day tripper you
might say
um my buddy
a few sundays ago
text me and said yo i'm going to be in
new orleans wednesday what is a day trip
does somebody who goes on a day trip
it's a beatles song you wouldn't get it
so but um okay that's right
biebel's song i just what is it it's you
just go you do things
you're just a guy who just goes and does
things yeah i'm not a rolling stone but
i take airplanes so anyways thanks for
interrupting me um anytime sundays
on a sunday my buddy texts me and just
says
yo i'm going to be in new orleans
wednesday through friday because i was
shooting it i was shooting a thing for
meta in austin name drop um
i've also i've had a little bit of
liquor already
ketchup but he sent me a picture of his
itinerary
and then before responding
i bought tickets with the exact
itinerary so that we landed and took off
at the exact same time in new orleans uh
and then i replied back and i was like
oh that's weird so am i
uh
and that and so
sunday to wednesday so that was what
three days
and then i just went there and we
[ __ ] partied
you
made your friend
think that you were also there at the
same time because if you had suggested
that you hang out they would have said
no
yeah you pretended them i forced myself
upon them it was you made yourself an
unavoidable encounter yeah mm-hmm i
respect like a like a pokemon i mean
they kept trying to avoid me but it's in
the tall grass waiting
to walk to the million city [ __ ]
i downloaded find my iphone so
they could not escape wow
yeah
what did you do
we just uh the first night we went hit
the town
uh had some
oh
we went to a fancy restaurant and then
we were being
really loud and they came and told us to
turn it down no
yeah and then we looked over
we looked over and there was this dude
with a with a giant beard in a flame
bandana
and we realized that it was one of the
stars of duck dynasty
oh oh [ __ ] yeah and so he's probably the
one that told us to shut the [ __ ] up no
i was going to say were you shouting
[ __ ] oh at the top of your lungs i
think
um i don't recall specifics but uh later
that night
uh uh this woman that we ran into that
the guy who lives there hunter
knows
she came with us
and then we had a heart-to-heart because
she was telling me about this vampire
bar that she knows about
and i was like wait real vampires and
she's like no that's just like the one
where they kind of court people to see
if they want to come to the real vampire
bar jacob what are you doing with your
face i love them jacob
jacob loves vampires i love bamboo oh
you get tickled as soon as somebody
mentions vampire is his favorite horse
jacob is his favorite skyrim dlc oh
that's a good dlc don guard oh full
that's good content yes so good
your clothes all pop off and you're a
sexy vampire it's great content
was that a mod it might have been
i don't know i just feel like i've been
ranting i want to hear from you guys
didn't we see a sneak peek of jacob's
xbox and he had the kissing mod for
skyrim
where did i see honestly john was
playing skyrim on our xbox
and uh
whoopsie daisy somebody oh yeah why do i
know that where did we see that i think
we talked about it here yeah
i saw it because i was staying with you
and i popped open skyrim yeah that mod
is great by the way
not just because of the smooching but
because when right when the characters
move into position the smooch their
character models go like
and then they kiss
it it's so funny as we all do naturally
yeah yes yeah luckily that was the only
mod that john
found
oh yeah i mean that was the community
approved ones because it was on xbox who
knows what you've downloaded for your pc
modding that was a community approved
mod yeah it was on
hell
excuse
should find go ahead john your place
looks awesome it does look like it looks
great it looks really really cool oh
wait hold on i pressed the button
shout out to celeste okay it's still
huge shout outs
let's just say
decorating uh
most of this stuff was like the only
stuff that i couldn't bring myself to
give away when i left the country
i love that dark souls poster i have i
have that one and i haven't put it up
oh really is that the one on your
shoulder that's that one that's that's
really pretty it's the world map i mean
really cool rahul did you know that that
the entire map if you like load
the loads of files it's all
interconnected like it's
it's [ __ ] awesome that's why i love
that's one of the reasons i love dark
souls so much this just makes me want
elden ring so bad
you've gotta wait a few weeks your [ __ ]
only chill out
it's only 23 days i have it i have a
little alert on my stream deck i've got
to finish dark souls for i've got two
games to finish you can call it elden
ring so i'm
simultaneously playing hades
and dark souls 3
and then hades and fifa
hades like everybody in hades is way too
hot they're so hot
all of them it's like being on the cw
just like being on the cw slightly more
diverse
yeah who's the
dionysus the one with the grapes and the
he pops like oh the drunk yeah yeah yeah
how's it going and like the first time i
saw him i was just like
damn they are i wanna it's gracious i
wanna um
fist aphrodite
yes who doesn't this anyway
oh you're just gonna give it away from
that by saying anyway yeah i've got
studies to do i've got a revision that's
so specific
who's one of the pushes the rock didn't
see it coming
oh
i want to bang that three-headed dog is
that sisyphus
okay either way like he could be on i'd
watch him write a symbiote
what's a good joke i don't get it i
really don't get it the one who pushes
the rock
oh
okay thank you with the emphasis i now
understand it that's a great one
it would have been better if you had
mentioned a wrestler from that era
because i don't know if kevin hart's
pushed him unless you mean pushing
pushes his buttons pushes
the rock
you went off about that in boulder
actually dude
he slipped up a little bit he's upset
he's upset the liberals recently
well because he supported joe rogan
really oh so now they're like [ __ ]
jumanji
[Laughter]
went straight for jamaica
i can't [ __ ] take it no more you
can't wait no there's just
by association your whole
filmography is thrown out because you
went fair enough mate
oh is it
last time i [ __ ] go and see jungle
cruise
that happened to
austin the other day
when somebody thought that he tweeted in
favor of nfts somebody like corrected
that he was making a joke and a person
replied and said oh i guess johnny is
good again
oh my god honestly i guess jeremy's good
again
the climate that we live in if if i had
to cut ties with every white supremacist
cyst i knew i wouldn't do that
yeah
i cut you off
that's your favorite joke i know that's
your fault oh my god
holy moly
so new orleans you've been there too
haven't you raffle anyways nightlands
oh yeah yeah i did a convention
there a few years ago
um
a rare appearance i don't like doing
conventions to be honest because
i don't like fan interactions about your
ego was just more inquiring about
new orleans as a city
um
it was a good city just went out and
smoked a lot of cigarettes with mads
mikkelsen noise whoa cool it is really
hannibal really cool architecture there
um didn't see any of it it's pretty
statin
just i was playing smash bros
that does sound like a pretty awesome
trip
super smash brothers i think it came out
that yeah yeah i was just playing it
that's all i did at the convention good
stuff that was your you played pre-sora
smash brothers correct
um why we're both leaving the point my
dad and i went there he really wanted to
go
and
had
big little wayne fan a huge she's a big
fan of wheezy
um
we had crocodile hot dogs
crocodile whatever very uh very tough
tough meat
oh that's
not all animals should are meant to be
eaten wait why would i get cancelled for
that
they're funny about weird meats i can't
say
a meat is tough or because i ate a
crocodile
yeah
they're endangered somewhere
probably yeah it's inhumane
i mean yeah no that's what they give you
like a like a crocodile skin jacket
afterwards made from the same crocodile
and the hot dog was made out of pants
because if you if you if you said that
you wore like leather shoes and you get
in trouble now right or goose feathered
electricity
like you can get in trouble for anything
and that's a complicated thing about the
human experience i'm sorry if there's
one thing i want to do is sell out and
wear branded
never
stuff i've been wearing those those
gundam dunks a lot dude that's so sick
thank you no
i got wipes i walked into the office
like i'm keeping them clean like
you got to keep them clean because
they're down now they're just [ __ ]
falling all over you i bet that they
just plummeted did we have a shower oh
yeah i'll go get
them on the podcast talk more about
nolan's
knowledge
do you have any other anecdotes
yes went to a cigar bar oh
oh my god
for the audio listeners people got a
great
but what people don't realize is jacob
has got really nice carves great games
yeah in it
yeah the gams he should show them all
yeah
but he never wears him out he only wears
them when i stay over
i mean score for you that's he's got to
keep himself pure for when you visit
he puts he puts shorts on and loads the
skyrim kissing mod yeah skyrim get some
pants pour some snoop dogg rose yep
that's it um well on night two
uh we did a uh a catfish fry
uh
god bless him
my favorite thing about watching the
vlog which john edited at patreon.com
you can see a boulder blog
uh vlog rather exclusive to patreon um
was all the jacob content that i didn't
know occurred there was so much good
jacob content it was basically just a
jacob vlog
excellent vlog
excellent there's a line that alana
didn't catch
uh so i had to
reiterate had to repeat what jacob said
which is where i said where's the [ __ ]
at
jacob went in the basement
something along those lines it was he
did it more orc it was like
that's incredible it is time for an ad
break this one is all about supporting
basically our own patreon if you didn't
already know this podcast is supported
by patreon this particular episode of
the show has an extended cut on patreon
already um it's an extra 20 minutes
where we talk about book of boba fett
that was cut from the very end and
published exclusively on patreon the
patreon version also has ad-free content
including at least one monthly exclusive
piece of content from idiots and abroad
plus you can ask us some questions for
the show and basically the more support
that we get the coolest stuff we're able
to do so that would include merch or
touring maybe we'll start doing live
shows in different cities maybe we can
make john that cocktail book that we
keep talking about so head over there if
you want ad-free versions of the show
more in-person episodes more vlogs and
extra content
it's snowing
wow
[Music]
beautiful
wow
[Music]
i'm wondering about
[Laughter]
i had no recollection of that before
watching the vlog yeah i didn't know
that that happened my favorite is that
then you hear you off camera go what
i haven't had that
very good
oh man it was a lot of fun it was it's
weird because like it's it's felt so
long since the last one you know last
podcast because this is the first time
in a while we haven't seen each other
yeah we should start
like
um
with a like chronologically which is
when we shot that there was still a few
more days of boulder right that's true
well we
we we recorded the podcast before the
new year's celebration basically right
yes yeah
so people haven't heard about all the
crazy shenanigans mostly a lot of jack
that's true
lot of face dunking and ice at minus 17
degrees celsius
heroes of the storm wait what's that
movie called hero the galaxy
oh
bastards of the storm is the universe
it's the game
masters of the universe i
loved it masters of the universe
which is my favorite fair one of my
favorite films ever because
frank langella who plays skeletor who
i've been praising for decades
is
in
the i'm in the show with him he's in the
fall of house of fashion oh my god boner
so
i've been i think they've been wanting
to watch it
[Laughter]
nice um
so i put it on
and i
gave so many warnings to you lot like we
hadn't seen it people hate this film
it's you know it's it's it's like one of
them like a cult [ __ ] like um [ __ ]
on movie
and
weirdly enough you loved it unironically
yeah i mean you told the i watched the
uh like the toys that made us oh you
watched that episode yeah and even in
that show they [ __ ] on the movie
dude
rahul i i understand the like the
hesitation you had
but like i i knew that i was probably
going to like it but when that when that
little goblin guy showed up with the
staff that
had like electronics on it yeah he was
like a future staff i was like
oh this is my [ __ ]
yeah i mean i was taking a nap because i
need a lot of naps but um when i came
down i also really enjoyed it you've
hyped that movie up to me for ages and i
still thought it was dope
yeah that's i i unironically praise it
like i have on social media and i do
think look
and there's a lot of stuff around it um
um
but like in terms of like the funding
being pulled and this isn't what uh
mattel wanted and like there's a whole
law behind how it got made dolph
lundgren his grasp of the english
language was wasn't great so he had to
redub everything because they couldn't
understand him it was wonderful
i thought he was great was the um
post-credits scene i've ever seen in um
yeah yeah they had a post credit scene
he pop skeltor pops out of the goop and
he's like i'll be back oh yeah and then
it just like freeze frames on it
never made another live action ever
again
um
but but the [ __ ] the thing about that
movie buried right in there in all this
like
star wars copying and stuff there are
some real a
plus stuff going on and like
langella's skeletor for me is like
insanely good like
he put richard the third lines in he was
rewriting stuff and like he took it to
the next level
um and i think the score as well bill
conti did the score the same guy did
rocky and carly i think i anyway i love
it you described uh i think like as like
going harder than he a hundred times
harder than he needed to yeah
and it really was like that like when he
did that monologue towards the end
during like the climax and i was like
wait he's transforming holy [ __ ] yeah
he's so cool
he's so good and like i i heard
my mike mike told me um
that he had a dinner with frank because
i haven't met frank yet at this point of
this recording
um
and they they had a dinner and mike told
me that he he mentioned to frank like
by the way you'll get one of the actors
on the show rahul
keeps saying that you're the you know
the one of the best movie villains ever
performances ever and he said that frank
smiled and leaned in and when i agree
so and he said he said he was down to
talk about it so like this is my first
ever movie like
my parents know it's not star wars
this is the the first one on tape this
is i mean about three years also on a
show with mark hamill
well if we i mean we're jumping ahead to
i should but yeah yeah
mark marcus mark is here yeah i mean
my mate marky mark
um oh i haven't we haven't spent a lot
of time together but all we did do was
uh i showed him loads of videos of jacob
and he [ __ ] hates him yeah
we just made fun of him i think mark
called him hamilton early headed [ __ ] is
what he called
jacob no
ruffle
show this show up a picture of this
[Laughter]
show a picture of this he'll like he'll
love it i actually do think that's
pretty sick because he got some kind of
cake
oh the kind of moth it looked like it
had those like moth
though he had this cape on and it was it
was awful i hated this [ __ ] i i'm gonna
do everything i can i like it's gonna
forget i'm gonna do everything i can
just realize to get a video on my phone
of mark telling jacob to [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
he's the reason he hates star wars i'm
going to get something horrible for me
oh good idea that is a good idea
jacob i deserve it no you don't but
boulder sorry we we yeah we do yeah we
watched martin's universe we watched the
mist we did we did yeah
that's two for two i recommended it
i recommended it and afterwards you said
john you're o for two recommended horror
movies yeah i love them my heart
sunk
you have maintained that record you've
yet to impress
most horror movies are garbage
but they're also fun that's true because
over two first movie was malignant
you've been killing it i'll be i'll i'll
admit rahul you don't like any horror
movies i do like what
dr sleet you're just gonna list the ones
that are mike flanagan
i think 28 days later is incredible it's
one of my favorite films is it yeah is
it a horror movie
what's it what is it what is it the
genre i believe is zombie
oh yeah that's true that's more of like
a different thrill thrilling horror
point is the shining a horror i like the
shining i think that's a psychological
thriller you didn't like the shining you
didn't like the shining you told me you
didn't like it parts of the shining i
said it was overrated
i liked the shining i like that one part
i like that one part where the pig is
blowing that guy
oh yeah that happens in the shining yeah
yeah it's like a little moment but i
like that she's a cute little naked lady
sexy lady shout out to her the old one
when she turns old name some horror
movies i'll name some aura movies um
horror movies exorcist i've seen oh i
think paranormal activity was fantastic
when it came it's more of like a gore
like gore porn
cramps
this is a horror movie paranormal
activity gotta be paranormal activities
found footage
it's a found footage movie obviously
actually no horror movies existed aren't
mike flanagan i liked the it remake
oh yeah
that's more of a coming of age i think
scream is good i like scream the
original [ __ ] that's more of a high
school
yeah slasher that's a slasher how about
tusk
oh god
that's gore porn
is it this is just where
kevin smith movie where justin
gets captured in this mansion by this
old dude
and then he like performs surgery and
turns him into this
horrific walrus into a wall right now oh
i'm looking at it like he like performs
all these crazy surgeries on him to make
him a wall so it's like a body horror
yeah like i i couldn't even finish the
trailer i was like it's not very well
i'm never going to watch this does
bother any of you
yeah yeah i can't well
i can't do this stuff where it's like
surgeries for like it's like why why is
this happening like i'm in centipede
i'm not into well i've said we've caught
my mom watching the human centerpiece on
three separate occasions
she's trying to get through it
no she's seen it and every time it was
either me and my sister we'd walk in and
my mom had a cushion here and she's
giggling behind the [ __ ] cushion
i don't know it's the weirdest thing
you're right so my
i was gonna mum up the human centipede
because like butter body horror makes me
uncomfortable but like like i like when
movies make me uncomfortable yeah i feel
like when a movie gets like a visceral
reaction out of me other than just being
like disgusting making you want to throw
up but actually making my skin crawl or
something i feel like it's effective
it's like accomplishing what it's set
out to do
oh
i liked hereditary oh yeah exactly
exactly even then though you were like
wasn't that good
the british the british latin you had to
say wasn't that good because it made you
a bit scared so to feel like you were
still tough you had to be like nah i
wasn't that good broth so that you felt
better about it
let me let me all of you shut up
[Laughter]
so
i think the first 40 minutes of
hereditary
is probably
one of the greatest horrors i've ever
seen i think it's absolutely [ __ ]
incredible there is a little drop for me
a little drop
uh but still had moments in there you
know tony collette that when you when
you see it i think it's brilliant up
until the ending it's the ending that
left me going
because when you when you start that
strong and then there's a drop and then
when and then right at the end that
extra bit that's that's the last thing
you walk away from that's why i was a
bit like yeah it was all right it's not
a great ending yeah yeah it was all the
old lady old people naked people correct
yeah you didn't like seeing old wayne
yeah just like which you see through the
whole movie to be clear
there's naked wings that whole film
personally
same thing with like don't breathe where
i'm like the whole movie was super tense
and then he whips out a turkey baster
yeah dude and i was like oh
come on i really want to see that movie
so please don't spoil more of it okay
it's good but here's the thing like that
mo that's one of those movies it's like
a thrilling horror is that right
no no no no no no
i bought the i bought the blu-ray
because i started getting back into
audio commentaries because i remembered
it from the early 2000s and how much i
loved like dvd special features and
stuff
so i that was one of one of the ones i
bought and i started listening to it and
it was
it was like dude these [ __ ] guys like
they were just like so this scene uh
yeah we just wanted to like do something
funny and so we did like it was the most
like basic there was no depth
to the movie that they had made at all
and like
it just made it more shallow listening
to the audio commentary so i stopped
it's it's funny you bring this up john
um
because physical release particularly
for a lot of stuff is dying
and netflix in particular and they're
not doing physical releases anymore so
you take
and
uh i was listening to a podcast and it
came up and i think and it was like it
was actually mike who mentioned this he
said that he wanted to do audio
commentaries because that was the best
part right he's done it for physically
he did it for for like
warner brothers because it was it wasn't
a netflix show but he's even said to
them hey like i'll do it in my own time
as an audio track within netflix so you
know how you can choose your language
dude i know
you're [ __ ]
you're right you're exciting me right
now right yeah that was like audio
option of just oh absolutely yeah now
watch squid game with the with the
commentary or watch or watch this or
watch whatever but yeah
well no you had us fall in love
yeah you either get english subtitles or
audio commentary you can't have those
you have korean squid game sub uh audio
but your [ __ ] boy doug who's mr
fluent
sitting next to you yeah
and i just misinterpret everything yeah
it tastes like the ocean and it was
actually talking about the
cinematography
that's what he was like let me do it
because at least that compensates for
the missing features thing
hell yeah oh my god so if any of our
listeners
want to start like a little ruckus
because they do respond to things like
that then if you want audio tracks keep
suggesting it for different yes
twitter bomb mic playing again
was like back in the heyday of dvds
that was the selling point for dvds the
commentary yeah well not even the
conversation like how many special
features can we fit
and like they because they they like
hired crews to shoot everything during
the whole filming
i'm all these little
special features of venom venom oh yeah
motorcycle you can see me go
so but you know you know the special
features thing was interesting on dvd
ladies and gentlemen
some some went hard in the paint like
fairly early on to adopt that because it
was still trying to find
its way and stuff but i feel like it
reached its real
like the most kind of
the highest point it reached that then
dictated how everyone else went forward
was peter jackson i think with when the
fellowship went extended
yeah
they dropped those special features i
feel like everyone stepped their game up
yeah i felt like i love that as they
keep increasing the quality of the lord
of the rings extended editions or
whatever um it's more and more obvious
when it's a a little child as a stand-in
yeah
not one of the actors
one of them is a fame is a
little indian fella um i don't know what
the pc took a little person little
person yeah a little personally he's a
little person well i i believe recently
little person is uh belittling
no pun intended and that dwarf is
because it's literally dwarfism i don't
[ __ ] know is this like how we've gone
back they're just saying death because i
feel like we we say deaf
and hard of hearing but i think that's
what they're trying to do
they're two different things man come on
come on
and then we came back so now we're
saying dwarfs well it says little people
of america is the association okay
so everyone says that escort is the pc
term but i really want to bring back
lady of the night or prostitute that
would sound like
i found out what it was by the way it's
sex worker and it's full sex worker
full sex worker
that's what i heard when i realized
that's interesting that's that's what i
had when i was that's what i heard oh
really that's where did you hear that
at the broad floor when i was eating
i said do you like being called sex
workers
you eat off
you're like dude
called chocolate
no it's good favor it's a manipulation
tactic
for the audio listeners everybody rahul
is raging pink guy right now
um
yeah bring back special features oh yeah
anyway
we've got special features
yeah i was just watching the lord of the
rings once like a day ago one of the one
of the things that's striking about
elijah and the
hobbits
is
because they're played by actors whose
limbs are proportionate to their size
and then
when you're a little person
there's a certain like warwick davis for
instance has a different type of walk in
the way he he carries himself
so when they switch between frodo's
double to frodo photos double to double
there is a mismatch in like movement
so they got this little i should i can't
really i don't know
go on can you get up and do it i'm just
gonna stop that did you survive speaking
of special features and to get this i
get this off of rahul for a second
that's like like the ewok adventures
special features it's just warwick davis
with a like a camera oh going around
backstage yeah and it's just it's just a
youtube video that's it it's all there
is
it's just him just filming stuff he
knocks on he knocks on like harrison
ford's door right
i don't know harrison ford's like [ __ ]
off
who is that
chewie it's uh i i think i know the
features it has a little youtube video
it's awesome if you guys want all of
this dope special features what i a few
a number of years ago i bought every
single fincher
uh like dvd slash blu-ray and i watched
them all with the audio commentary
that dude
is like a technical
like
he's so much more detailed than anyone
else
he might be and when you do 70
75 [ __ ] takes yeah yeah
wait uh my favorite my favorite candy
tote was when i was watching panic room
he was like you know we just finished uh
we just finished fight club and like
there were so many scenes in that script
there was like a fourth of a page
where it was you know something being
some big thing happening where we had to
get a huge crew out to like shoot this
one little 15 second scene and like i
just wanted something simpler so i
picked panic room because it it all
takes place in a house and like it's all
one location
and then he was like but then i thought
about the idea of like having the camera
be autonomous and like omnipresent
uh so then we designed basically they
just the whole house in panic room all
the walls are movable the entire
like three floor house is modular
and he said that it was it was way more
complex
that's funny like he tried to chill but
because he's uh because he
couldn't that's awesome
we
where are we chronologically in our
trips right now we movie nights in
boulder yep
we got here from the mist somehow and
then we tried really hard to try and do
something snow related on the day that
it snowed where it was beautiful um
but you know we tried maybe we were like
let's go like maybe we get a little sled
and we just go down a hill like children
sold out
yeah we'll really get anything really
the i feel like the the main snow event
that we did which was uh gearing me up
for the snow
yes giving you clothes yeah terrible
choices what kind of footwear did you
have for this trip i had moccasins
[Laughter]
i still don't understand
i mean by the way look at that watch
this
oh
wow i didn't expect that oh
yep
your [ __ ] ball
wow are you going to have moccasins
again right now though no i'm wearing
slippers thank you very much same thing
we forgot about that oh it hurts
[Laughter]
our audio listeners will love that
like you're being [ __ ]
yeah
and go a little bit lower so we can't
see her
there you go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it looks so real
oh my goodness gracious
that's so rough
oh jesus
terrible we're trying to film a podcast
he definitely likes it rough a little
[ __ ] look at him
worn out [ __ ] hell let me just flip
these back down
oh god
very good very nobody no no gifts
no absolutely no gifts of that everybody
be respectful jacob didn't know that
that was being recorded he thought that
that private moment would remain private
um
anyways so we got this
we made face we made face oh yeah
imprints in the snow i don't remember
what we spoke about last time i think we
spoke about the fires and we spoke about
yeah being annoyed at people
yeah yeah because we were shopping the
first like 45 minutes was just bitching
about stuff
that's a good thing a lot of comments
the last one a lot of the comments on
the last one was how psychotic and upset
and i didn't speak for the first 12
minutes it was pretty weird well i
forgot to read the comments they're all
reading between the lines like
you know is that it was the acting or
whatever
and said hey that part where rahul asked
you to put your hand inside of the
dorito was really disgusting
because of my reaction which is
obviously a joke
they were like that was really [ __ ] up
how do you people don't know
we're friends i don't understand
there's a really good gift of that
though yeah go ahead there's a good gift
of it i'm gonna answer i'm gonna answer
both of those points okay one
okay i know you like to read between the
lines and create your own narrative so i
just want you to all to know that i was
genuinely in a [ __ ] mood when i
started the podcast most of you were
right yeah i was pissed off i don't know
why i just wanted to get in moods
jacob's being so annoying
interrupted you when you were trying to
listen to a podcast for 40 minutes to
hear your own name mentioned
oh yeah
that's why you're a mess
that happened afterwards yeah it didn't
happen
that's the thing that occurred yeah no
you've got to explain it all right well
now i've got to explain this no you
don't it's fine this happened afterwards
all it was right is i'm starved for
attention and sometimes right even
though i have a very strong father
figure i always seem to need extra
fatherly love from someone and i'm
waiting for mike to turn around and say
i wish she was my son or something like
that you know something small like that
some validation i've been working on
four projects and then
he does a he does a podcast for like boo
crew or something
and i'm listening and i'm listening i'm
just listening why not and they finally
said the question was
and everyone else was doing their own
[ __ ] thing and i had headphones in
and the question was
i was oh yeah i went out for a cigarette
and it goes
mike
rahul coley and sam sloyan phenomenal
performances in midnight mouse we have
to ask what's it like to work with those
two actors in particular
and you're just as mike was about to
answer john came out to have a [ __ ]
cigarette with me
hey what you doing
how you doing
i felt so bad because from my
perspective yeah from my perspective i
went out and you and you're like
[Laughter]
it was like oh no he wanted to be alone
i'm being overbearing
are you sure it wasn't like you were
caught jacking off
i was investing yes
you went outside at minus 12 to do it he
also went he went like this
i'm not doing anything
funny enough when i after the 10 minute
cigarette that we had talking about
absolutely nothing so i could get back
to the podcast
um
you might kind of might kind of glossed
over it anyway
so
so why were you pissed off before we
recorded the podcast
sugar levels who knows
[ __ ] tiny breakfast
yeah tiny bro but
the other thing is about the pringle can
incident yes
is
if you're a group
and you all are doing comedy and you're
all ragging on each other and having fun
and this and this and this
you weirdos who think it's different
that you should isolate the woman and be
like now now let's not curse in front of
the lady that's more [ __ ]
misogynistic
than if you just treat everyone like a
[ __ ] equal yeah so if i'm gonna offer
a can of pringles on my crotch to john
and jacob it's weirder if i'm not doing
it to me would be strange yeah yeah i'd
be like there's this weird white night
thing of like now now
come on she's not going to sleep with
you bro
yeah that's why that one comes out that
lady in the throat
do you want for equality
i'm in agreement treat me the same way
you treat anyone else don't be nice to
me i'm all i always think it's weird
if um
just flags if i ever hear a guy say well
men and women can't be friends
and i say that all the time i'm like
are you sure about that though or is
that a youtuber i've never heard you say
that
they cannot be friends only lovers only
love us um
yeah or like don't swear around girls or
you shouldn't make jokes like that
around girls well like people say that
about streams sometimes if i'm streaming
with you guys or whoever else and they
make like a dirty joke and they're like
i can't believe they talk this way
around a woman like no it's weird if you
don't allow this a lot
can i give these guys a little bit of
advice what's that yeah sure you [ __ ]
chad if you want to get some [ __ ]
gash yeah you got to treat him like one
of the boys you understand
if you want to get [ __ ] a puss
jacob laughed so hard that's such a dunk
[Laughter]
it's a good word
[Laughter]
i prefer a man who treats me the same
way as they treat their male friends
except for like the like arm punches and
whatever
the part where you like fart around each
other lessons there was that good gif of
it where like rahul you got the pringle
can and you gesture towards elana she's
just like
and then my arm comes in from my screen
just goes straight into it
your [ __ ] feet
you're a [ __ ] fiend
um so
then on the timeline
yeah we failed to do any kind of
sledding and we're like guess we give up
on that then because we all get any
equipment all our frolicking was just
like we went to like get like a nice
brunch and we just walked in the snow
and like we were shoved we were
shuffling snow off the car which was
really fun the funniest thing was like
we went to a diner really nice they had
yeah those are the last thing we did i
knocked like a cat on somebody or
something i think it did yeah oh
yeah there were like bottles on the
shelves and you hit them with your head
and they fell on the people on the other
side
i was watching the liverpool game so i
didn't talk to any of you
yeah that was like a whole day that's
correct
yep you're sitting in the dead or when
you're pretty upsetting we're like okay
we're gonna go to the airport now yeah
love that no but like the we shovel well
we had a lot of punch getting stolen one
point didn't at one point during that
diner meal we were all just sitting
there talking and rahul just goes
it is time to talk about the 2021 video
game accessibility awards delivered by
pizza hut this is an award show that i
created and then i write and host and
produce alongside one of my best friends
steve spahn and it is all about
celebrating accessibility in video games
making sure that more people are able to
play video games this year's iteration
of the show celebrating the games that
came out in 2021 will be taking place on
march 12th and it will be an hour maybe
an hour and a half long stream where we
run through the games that have done a
great job in the interest of encouraging
more developers to get involved but also
just celebrating this part of the
industry a very big thank you to pizza
hut for helping us out to make sure that
we can afford to run the show and make
cool graphics like this and what you're
looking at right now is actually um just
an update on the categories we changed
them from what they were last year so
creative use of second channel is now
called second channel and this stuff may
not make sense to you but i'll have
another video breaking down uh what all
the categories actually mean and we're
going to be announcing nominees later
this week um so i'm super excited if you
want to tune in to the show it will be
all about video game accessibility but
has a real focus for me on being fun and
funny and light-hearted we think we're
going to have some stand-up comedy in
there as well so please do stay tuned if
this is something that you would like to
support and a very big thank you to my
partners at ablegamers pizza hut and
real good touring for helping me make it
bigger and better this year the video
game accessibility awards will be
broadcast live on my youtube channel and
a whole bunch of other places that we
are yet to announce
on march 12th i think essentially yes
john buried me in snow and we had a
fight
we
i do still feel really bad about it you
shouldn't you really shouldn't it was
fun so
during the boulder trip that was my
first time i think i have footage of
that let me pull it up you do i
for some reason i cut it from the vlog i
don't know oh because it makes somebody
look guilty
oh i wonder why that was coming from the
vlog so i had a bucket list
because i've never really been in snow
and so one of them was i stripped down
my underwear and i ran a loop around the
apartment we included that
yeah another one was uh throwing us
making and throwing a snowball which i
did to jacob from about three feet away
yep
in the chest another one i didn't
realize until it was happening and i was
doing it
was
tackling jacob holding him down and then
rubbing snow in his face here we go i
found it hang on pull this over
everybody this is the coldest time of
the year
that's the only time i've ever seen
jacob genuinely upset and cry yeah he it
it [ __ ]
for him to wind back down i'm showing
the footage to the to the internet you
guys just can't see it because that
would be annoying okay
i'm gonna go refill my water
like i was having fun just having i
think my maybe just got the tail end no
okay yeah i've got jacob on the ground
and uh i think rahul's just casually
standing there and observing like
nothing you see my can you see my sick
jacket i was being like a dad when i
thought they were going too far i'll
pull them off but for now man up
it's funny in this vlog john looks
apologetic
he's by his body language i'm not even
losing the audio i couldn't see anything
i just remember like we were rough
rolling around the snow and it was fun
and then the
iciest most bitter cold i've ever felt
hit the skin of my face and i couldn't
breathe anymore it was so snowy you
hugged it out yeah he's clearly
apologetic
um yeah totally yeah
it was it was fun it was beautiful like
yeah i've never experienced it like that
no it was so nice it was so quiet it was
like especially like fall fresh fall and
just like stomping in it i was having
some noises
yeah the parts of the vlog were like
we're just getting snow off the car
like that was really fun yeah and it was
fun because there was somebody in their
like apartment just like oh you guys
yeah you're doing great oh yeah that
dude yeah those people who came out and
we were like what do we what do we do
exactly
oh there's the facebook yes i posted
that on patreon actually already um
yeah they were like yeah you know you're
doing pretty good yeah you'll figure it
out it was fun to problem solve that
together the funny as far as like you
posted that clip on the uh
on your instagram i'm just just like
shoveling the snow off the top with the
slow motion and stuff very good and john
feeling me getting snow very good it
shoveled on me and people are like oh
sick you got a kia soul
i had so many people message me and be
like you know that you just showed your
license plate in a video yeah
i'm not [ __ ] dumb
yeah
what give me some credit like it's not
my car i did not buy a kia soul i
continue to not have a vehicle
i know surprising they're like they look
it up they go
alana owns a car rental company
this whole enterprise
i must go there and inform her no i do
not um now the case ksl did us did us
pretty well when you guys like
tires when i'm cutting the kia soul
[ __ ] rocket just the whole time
i'm the only one who drove it yeah which
i think is a control freak issue yeah i
think that except except i didn't drive
it when
jacob wanted pizza
oh yeah and i drove up my line and he
drove it on his alone and i should have
said hey i'll come with you because it
was really bad conditions but because i
had my 6 30 couldn't eat after 6 30.
didn't want anything to do
i didn't want to be in a [ __ ] car
with pizza so i let baby boy jacob drive
in hazardous conditions
the best part was like it was the last
day we were there and this the road was
really snowy and stuff so the car was
naturally drifting a lot like but we
were going so slow nobody who wasn't
driving wouldn't notice so you were just
sitting the driver's seat like oh
cause did like an alert come on on the
dashboard every time it started sliding
and so we were all just like hanging out
and writing it
you can feel it sometimes but to me it
felt like you like you were doing it way
more often than i could feel it yeah
because what no all it was was that
you'd feel the you'd lose control of the
wheel yeah so it's like it's
you it's this really weird it's almost
like your controller disconnects right
yeah
or you're you've got lag or something
right so you're going
and you lot are just chilling and i'm
like not in control of this [ __ ]
is it rarely like it rarely you guys
fire but where
felt it you got us where we needed to go
just fine yeah then we drove up a
mountain the day you guys headed to the
airport
yeah we had a look at
the what's it called
uh rocky mountain national rocky
mountains the rocky mountain yes what's
it called
the rocky mountains
um beautiful absolutely beautiful wiggle
got mountains in england
every box
it was it was very pretty um and as we
like went on this beautiful walk through
this national park through the woods
stunning there was just this [ __ ]
loud as [ __ ] family
oh really not that peaceful not that
peaceful
just yelling about sort of everything
praying for a [ __ ] avalanche
although they caused one well we would
have died too
i would have been around no you would
have snowboarded down it like some cool
cats
the avalanche would have come and then
you just would have jumped up and done a
front flip over he's pretty tall
you say that but i i wanted to film a
video of me
at full pelt
rocky iv run up the side of the mountain
oh
like the montage yeah and um
didn't turn out great no i barely make
it up i'm laughing in the entire
background of that
really want to see video that sounds
amazing oh if it you need to get the
rocky music on there
yeah and you cut out all the parts where
you're like heaving and like no we found
a
recorder edit of i found i found someone
doing the rocky
iv
and the original rocky but you know like
how they do the bad titanic one yeah so
i wanted to rip it
i'm busy in it i've got [ __ ] to do i
don't need productivity to me i'll do it
all right i think you already did it
it's just it was embarrassing so you
didn't publish it no no i didn't oh i
want to see it because i couldn't rip
the youtube audio from the flute to
put it in so that's me i promise i won't
upload it yeah
oh
i said i'm home safe and you guys said
why are you texting me
no one asked you to let me i'd
understand if we said let us know if you
guys i would have
i am the mom friend there's no way that
i wouldn't ask that
that was a delightful trip it was fun it
was so much fun
you did seem like you were in a bad mood
the whole time but that's because you
couldn't eat off to 6 30. yeah you have
like a four hour window it does
something to a man
um now we had a great time and i think
like
i don't think we have
well no we
might get you out here
um and then next month it looks like
we'll probably go to san francisco
fingers crossed oh my god that'd be cool
i'm gonna i'm gonna geek out that whole
time
i was nervous because like i i had a
thing but the date moved
yeah so if we go for gdc which is
obviously what i'm going for and john
and i have tried to do it for gdc rules
jacob would you be able to we can figure
this out off the podcast yeah yeah
oh my god when you mentioned it
previously you're like oh yeah i'm doing
i'm doing a hosting thing at gdc and i
was like oh yeah i was like hosting like
a panel about like mental health and
video games or something sounds like
something i would do yeah but then i saw
the tweet that was like
hosting in all of gdc on the main stage
i was like what the [ __ ] i am the mc of
gdc it's this is a really really cool
one like
i i went to gc seven years ago i looked
up as a reporter and i was like holy
[ __ ] this is so cool and there's no
world in which i ever would have guessed
that they would ask me to emcee it like
this like
of all the stuff that i've done i had a
disney tv show
i don't um whatever i'm a to the
when they accepted it it i was just so
like it's [ __ ] awesome because gdc is
so cool and it's like it's very game dev
focused it's not public focused so yeah
they didn't ask me to do it because
they're trying to get the public in it's
for game developers yeah i'm really
excited
genuine oh my god i really don't know
what to expect yeah it's cool
for those of you that don't know what
gdc is it's game developers conference
and um for most people i think from the
outside is they upload so for decades
now
they've been filming every single
lecture
and on their site you can subscribe and
it's like super it's like and they talk
about it a year nobody talks about it
yeah and they have like over a decade
they they even have iwata's like wii
presentation or something
from back in the day where he does that
quote where he's like
in my mind i'm do you do the accident
how does he say it
i don't remember was what does he sound
like
we did accents on the last one so it's
okay to do it again this time but but
when he says in my heart i am a gamer
um well if you want by the way a lot of
the comments from last episode uh were
from mexican people who fully were happy
i can give you the stats i know i
basically i did like an italian
friendship i didn't do a mexican accent
and i still don't want to i still don't
want to encourage you to do it but um i
can't tell you that uh there were
for every person who's like a mexican
don't care find it funny there was only
one person who was like would prefer if
he didn't
did you block them and immediately i was
like [ __ ] off [ __ ] no i was like um
no don't do that people are
allowed it's only [ __ ] white people
that are [ __ ] bitching about for the
most part yes that is true
that's why when you guys do an
australian accent um i get really
offended by it i wouldn't stoop to that
level to do
such a stupid accent shut up [ __ ] it's
black history month
it is i'm raising money for black ghost
code one of my favorite organizations
dude i love that video i just saw that
like a few days ago
yeah because she's she's she's
australian and is she
yeah i think she's
no she's like running oh my god there's
something about it people look so cute
when they run but i don't shut up
it is very good that's awesome
um it is true so then timeline is then
that john went to new orleans
yeah oh yeah but hold on just i forgot
uh cdc right sorry if you're a person in
public it's really interesting that on
their youtube they put some of their
lectures up
and they're super awesome like if you if
you like a gamemaker's toolkit for mark
brown then you'll love all those gdc if
you've
if you've had or have any interest in
sexual intercourse you will not find gdc
interesting
i've got enough plus i'll go excuse me
i love gdc and i am no longer a virgin
what's huzzah sorry born again virgin
um anyways yeah oh yeah nollins
knowledge knowledge
that was basically it
doesn't work for audio listeners mate
what
elana what she's doing right now doesn't
work for audio listeners
elon's zooming in on her stupid camera
stupid face oh she's doing front flips
well she's so talented oh my god elana's
doing like super offensive hand signal
oh she's trying to get us more views
[Laughter]
you're a gdc host i can't do that on
camera
i was trying to look displeased put
those
branded shelves and dressers
put the [ __ ] orcs away love you're a
video game writer for christ's sake
this is how much this is harassing god
of war
what are the are those like cabinets hey
did you lock it did you not notice hey
did you not notice how uncomfortable
alana looked when we were making those
jokes oh my god
yeah it's true um these behind me i'm so
glad you asked thank you anytime anybody
asked me about collectibles i will take
the floor uh prime one sent them to me
um and let me just [ __ ] show you
shall i are they a [ __ ] sponsor are
they a sponsor they're just getting a
shout out and they're getting a shout
out because they sent me these are just
like some sick ass statues
[Laughter]
i unplugged my uh webcam yeah did
youtube there
we go
what the [ __ ] okay just gank it off your
computer to show it to all your cool
stuff
you see him
wait a longer before you
haven't got packages anywhere have you
no no no i'm fine what i was worried
about was the dev kit but it's behind
the the box oh you have mexicans
poke bottles on your desk like i do
yeah a couple probably a few dollars
that ball just makes it look like you're
[ __ ] getting yourself off man you're
constantly doing your bounce you're
doing this little like [ __ ] rock and
it's [ __ ]
i had it i had it when i did my drunk
souls thing on like right before boulder
and i tried to get on and i fell the
[ __ ] off
do you guys want to see something cool
hang on let me see what i can do jacob
this is what i do with my ball
i just saw your face
all right guys watch this
i can't yeah let's see it
he's john is doing i'm gonna do this
like it's npr if anyone would like to
join me so right now
we're watching john uh smith as he
approaches
uh doing the olympic ball roll uh yes
that's very nice that was a beautiful
execution actually um jacob how did you
feel about john's um
this is a lot of visual references i'm
sorry banging yourself to our 2000
audience
i'm trying to do it with the leg right
you got to have your elbows off camera
okay there like this
yeah the elbows the hiding i don't know
why i can buy jacob's but not raffles
no
[Music]
i don't want you
forward bring your shoulders together a
little bit more
that just yeah like you've got little
legs
it's like a set of tiny arms yeah so
yeah gdc is very cool um if you want to
learn all about game development that's
kind of the purpose it's not a public
facing show it's more of a game
developer facing show
um we will be there i guess
probably but yeah vamp maybe vampires
are real maybe they are who knows
i could believe in anything and then
john went to new orleans yes what date
did you go new orleans new orleans huh
what date did you go to new orleans i
don't even know man
because it's important because
chronologically i've probably been here
is the reason that you decided that this
particular episode has to be
chronological because you were like i
get to speak first [ __ ] i get
to talk about how i felt in boulder and
then i went to vancouver it's the rahul
show
oh you know what if you complain i just
won't speak for another 12 minutes i
don't care
oh i think rahul is a little bit upset
during this podcast do you everybody
notice everybody notice rowell's little
bro
can you not insult your audience jacob
please
camel is gonna be very upset with you
come
now who is responsible for that
that's really strong okay john when did
gene begin when did you go i'm googling
it okay
you're googling your own trip listen
i have smooth brain i can't remember
anything oh
like genuinely i think maybe it's
because i
would that i abused adderall for like
multiple years
and i stayed up for like 36 hours every
weekend
my memory is shot don't do drugs
yeah don't do drugs oh speaking of drugs
i had some weed gummies for the first
time ever
okay this is i'm so happy for you jacob
but i'm also kind of offended because i
tried to get you on the weed game i
can't believe you didn't open the
podcast with this was it was it to take
the edge off for you jacob is that what
it was
he just needed to get rid of his
temperature
yeah i'm ready to burst at any moment
how much he loves edging
um i mean i think i i've only done it
once so far um and it just kind of i
don't i don't really know
did you how many gummies did you eat
i thought you and i were going to hang
out over here in the pure corner
no no sorry
strange
i mean i'm also i i still drink and
stuff but no i it really just kind of
knocked me out made you tired yeah yeah
was it indica or yeah
i have multiple questions
i don't know it tasted like pears
oh
so is it 2.5 milligrams or is it 5
milligrams each serving uh
2.5 2.5 yeah and does it say anything
about does it say hybrid indicator
sativa on it uh
are we gonna get demonetised because
we're talking about drugs no no no also
it doesn't matter no clue thanks legal
but i'll thank you for watching yeah but
like i don't get no patreon money no but
the show runs from patreon so if it gets
demonetized because you said [ __ ] too
many times which you do get in trouble
for on youtube
thank you patreon for buying me this
ring light in the hotel room i really
appreciate it
you're all blown out yeah yeah you
really made you look like it's too
bright he's as wide as i am yeah
no but like i've always been like i
never i've never wanted to like um
inhale anything yeah you know i just
didn't want to like mess with my lungs
at all so i felt better
an edible yeah like that's why i felt
better about this
what about mushrooms
i'm actually not allowed i'm i'm not
allowed to talk about anything this is a
state you're in
well no
not the state because i'm applying to a
job at a reputable
place
i might be rejected because of my online
presence and i was like oh [ __ ] well i
have an online presence and i work at a
reputable video game company that's true
but this one is a lot more family
friendly ah
i'm applying this green
week
yes
i could get upset about
i don't do drugs yeah
you
stop it
i'm not i'm trying to guess where he's
from
you said he said italian
oh
hey mario does more mushrooms than
anybody that's true that's true blizzard
italy
anyways it was it was good i'll eat two
yeah orleans was cool what happened
after new orleans
[Laughter]
who is that i click stop video what is
it
it says host has stopped my video
for the audio listener
what is that people aren't supposed to
see that
is that your uncle
happened
whoever it is i gotta give her a
controversy
okay i'm sorry hang on give him his
camera back
i don't think you can activate his
camera there you go so
a lot of
my
meetings now directed
like producer meetings and you know we
they want to talk on zoom about a future
project or whatever
[Music]
that's my zoom profile picture
[Laughter]
i so it always i like the idea that like
some of the people i've met uh
because it because i have to accept and
use my video they sit with that for a
second
can you explain what it is
i i just searched indian man on google
images
yeah something like that and i just made
it my profile picture so like say it's
james cameron and we were talking about
avatar for instance i like the idea that
just for a second
and he's like what
uh it just catches them off guard and
then i'm there and also
and then you know i thought it would
just default to your name
no ah
incredible
it was weird cause it did that earlier
but it didn't come back when he joined
it's true there it is look at that man
incredible it's okay this show is like
massively it's like 100 000
youtube versus 2000 audio we love you on
your business
we love you not many of them come watch
us buy a computer you poor [ __ ] he
just left then
now he's just gone he's like gone gone
yeah you'll have to invite him again
i think he'll be able to just click the
link
i'll have to accept him again though
quick is there anything we want to talk
about now that rahul yeah while rahul is
gone um i think it's ridiculous that
mark hamill is the best friend that the
brits
will call their front yard they call a
front garden and their backyard they
call it garden regardless of if there's
a garden regardless there doesn't have
to be a garden present at all but they
will call it a front garden and a garden
rather than just a yard front and garden
sounds like [ __ ] stupid like bush or
something
well yeah i know i thought front garden
is like term for muff yeah it's oh i
think it's ridiculous nobody nobody's
trimming their front garden oh you left
i didn't kick you out rahul was john's
fault he sent me a [ __ ] picture in
chat of some topless indian dude with
his belly out
okay and then when i opened i was trying
to close it and i closed it
[Music]
here is the picture everybody if you
would like to see it there you go
that's what it was beautiful yeah it
closed my zoom sorry that's what
happened when i googled indian man
selfie that's right okay so did you
manage to also google when you went to
nollins
we'll never find out i forgot
uh it was january
mid-january
house vancouver woods
how's that
my name is rahul coley
can you give me your best like
infomercial you're talking to me about
herpes
go
hi
i'm royal coley and i'm here to talk to
you about herpes i do feel comfortable
even though i look like kim jong-un
because
yeah
a little bit you look like randall park
playing kim jong-un god bless um he
looks pretty good
yeah i came out i came out
you came out three weeks ago
i think three weeks ago
flew up to vancouver
to begin production on the fall of the
house of russia exciting
yeah uh
it's edgar allan poe what uh what's
what's uh what's your character
it's a character and they're trying to
get you to slip off spoilers i won't
slip up who's my camel play oh [ __ ]
he plays a character in the show that's
compelling did they get usher
yeah he's doing the music
oh
i hope he does
it'd be amazing if the show is like
super super just like typical mic but
for no reason now
that's just like how in lit guardians of
gothel there's an owl city song
or like how in uh arcane there's like a
animated cameo of
they're like on the street performing
it's so weird i just don't feel like it
fits in the show not at all great show
but boy howdy
was it weird when they're hey
imagine dragging these nuts
that's actually pretty good
that actually works because it's
dragging i wonder if they've heard that
before
they listen to the show
liz we were talking about edgar allan
poe didn't we like we were looking at
the cast of other edgar allen poe things
we realized that uh oliver jackson cohen
cohen was in um the raven which
john cusack was edgar allan poe who
where he's uh from what uh why blind
manor and what happened
yeah yeah
i've only seen the first two episodes oh
you've seen the bad ones
if we are going to talk about star wars
boba fett spoilers we should save that
for the very end yeah or we do it
separately
okay so rahul how's vancouver
so it's fine
okay um all right moving on tell me one
thing that stands out to you about uh
being in vancouver what's one thing that
culturally stands out
so
the arrogance
of the canadians
um they think they are that they think
they're the [ __ ] they're license plates
say
their license plates say
beautiful british vancouver
[ __ ]
yeah okay that upsets you do you know
how [ __ ] arrogant that is right and
let me tell you something it's anything
but view but beautiful since i've been
here i've had to pay import duties on
miniatures
yeah
uh my uh amazon delivery and stuff like
that they don't even have next day
delivery takes up to five six days
import tax stuff in canada
is it's a mess
well there's also like terrorist attacks
going on there currently well i was
gonna get to that but more importantly
yeah it's chronological firstly i would
prioritize my warhammer
my the warhammer stuff that that i've
had to pay import tax on really pissed
me off
and then there's been some stuff about
like terrorism and the freedom convoys
and the swastika flags but more
importantly the warhammer
uh
40k delays really [ __ ] put a spanner
in the works yeah yeah trying to paint
an ultramarine up in this [ __ ]
um
yeah it's been fine i haven't actually
started as of today you were saying you
have a friend who had to
forgot to bring a laptop for their
child's school
correct and then
shipped it and had to pay like a
thousand dollars import tax
on a laptop for school oh yeah yeah
canada
wild
and i think i think she had to dispute
it and write so like they they've you
know it's this isn't a purchase this
isn't this it's a used laptop i know the
estimated value they took from that or
they did something
made out that it was how much she paid i
ended up paying a thousand i've had to
do it out
huh
oh sorry i was
what
what
what
what
yeah what what nothing
just like that scene what
what
he just slapped his seat in the
lighthouse
my favorite thing about that movie is
that there's a uh
there's a [ __ ] imessage sticker pack
for it
oh you know what that was off yeah i
want jacob do you have a you have an
iphone right i do i'm going to text you
this [ __ ] right now it's so [ __ ]
funny to me for some reason there's a
sticker pack for that movie my favorite
thing about that movie is patch is is a
is robert pattins's climax sound
here he goes
[Applause]
is it with all the funny faces
there's here
or is it some photos is it like photo
i'm sorry i cut you off with a wall
holy [ __ ] i know you're talking about
laptops
look how weird this is though
for for of all movies
nice
it's very strange is there an emoji of
the mermaid
i guess this isn't confidential
uh guess who i've been dming with and
i'm gonna go do their podcast
who stevie weeby
are you [ __ ] me
oh my god can we consider it um an
idiots in a broad stevie weeby show
official crossover
no i'm going to despite not having your
consent yeah i guess so crossover
everybody believe i'm going to be on the
stevie weeby show you basically oh yeah
universe crossover super
jazz because it's just you know
[Music]
no he said he said you were uh we i i
him because of one of those one of my
favorite clips of him and and
bobby
uh so i used that story and then he
replied and was like oh dude you were
great in midnight mass
uh long shot would you be down to like
come on the podcast
and i wrote back
remember when
um
what i saw what did i say i said
remember when i did that monologue about
um
what happened to me after 9 11.
that was a good one right
so i did his own joke back at him from
twilight but he didn't he didn't get
what he didn't get
he's like i don't remember that i don't
know it's just i don't remember his
brother
[Laughter]
that fell flat but yeah so next time i'm
i'm in i'm in l.a i'm gonna go on stevie
weeby's show cool well that's not in
chronological order with the stories
that we're trying to tell so that's true
it is because that actually he messaged
me before i went to vancouver well
speaking of chronological order
did anything else happen in in january
because i have a very
very special in there i've got a new
tooth so if you go back to older
episodes you'll see here there's oh you
don't have all your teeth um i'm british
oh right okay so raffles in vancouver i
went to bed
i went to whistler it was am i allowed
i mean if you want jacob and i can hold
the fort down yeah i'll stay here i
don't feel bad just going for a ciggy
i don't care no do you think for audio
listeners they would never do that on
the tv show though
did you send that back jake if you did
look at him you betcha oh my god my
lighthouse emojis of all films why on
earth does the lighthouse have a sticker
pack i like the light i like the lime
robert patton says like oh boy if i had
a steak i'd [ __ ] it
what a weird film
i love it i love the batman this weird
ass [ __ ] yeah that's coming out soon in
it it's pretty close hang on the batman
also jacob i i don't remember if i
texted this to you today but i was going
to be like if you ever wanted to just
like come over you could we could film
this in the same room you could always
you could do this that's really true
just next to it we are both in la and we
like we're basically neighbors pretty
close by yeah yeah yeah we'll do that
next time we'll do that next stop march
4th the batman i'm i'm looking forward
to it i don't have like super high
expectations
but i'm excited oh
john almost took out that kalax shell
but you have to say it like it's npr uh
here we see john smith professional ball
roller um
almost took out a shelf i believe he
said uh jacob um yeah from the from left
to right john smith dove across the room
he did um stomach on ball almost
demolished that kalax shelf from ikea
one with it it has the drawers in it not
all that stuff now he is
branded
yeah what's up
can i show you what cigarette packets
look like in canada sure yeah yes
they go so hard on them are you ready
for babysitting uh they're pretty bad in
australia show us a long i hope this one
this one's got a little alarm
uh asthmatic
she's just giving her oh that's not bad
at all that's not bad at all you should
see the australian one no no they have
those ones too we have them in the uk
like teeth dead people feet that are
[ __ ] up
the crazy one all right so they've made
them really uncomfortable and wide for
no reason and you have to push them like
this it's so cumbersome
smoking causes blindness
well which is crazy because when i went
for that contact yeah
2015 2015. is that the eagle eye vision
it's the best one a human being can have
it's a rare one yeah but it's like you
can see farther better like this
there is no markings on it there is no
nothing
like they've removed because they gotta
stop it from being sexy
well then uh they need to me to stop
smoking i
mean got you there
um
so i before we get to to your
shenanigans john
uh did visit rahul in vancouver went to
whistler which is a place that i wanted
to go my whole life because it's like
very hyped up i was just about to go for
a cigarette you can leave what do i need
you for
get out wait you're leaving in the
middle of this he wants to take a
cigarette
you went for a piss really appreciate
you
and i forced it out it took 40 seconds
that was quick
and then he did a sick role when he came
back can you do a trick when you come
back
yeah all right all right we're going to
leave in the middle of the podcast
that's actually pretty dope
[Laughter]
my god i wish i had a cool excuse to
leave here in the middle of the podcast
we know who we are so whistler is very
well known in australia like bizarrely
so to the extent that i feel like even
people who live in america don't
necessarily know what it is but
australians do
um it is
a place uh hour and 40 minutes or so
outside of vancouver that is known for
snowboarding and skiing basically
and it's very popular with australians
because it's so easy to get the visa to
go over there because of the
commonwealth so there are loads of
australians there i would have heard i
don't know thank you queen 20 indeed um
praise her
and
they have a sausage roll pie shop that's
australian
it was so good
that sounds dope
um but i wanted to go there my whole
life and it was it was very cool to
finally get to go did not go
snowboarding but i think i might do that
in big bear sometime soon
um yeah you know actually l.a yeah but
it was great
because it's it's uh
themed or sorry was built around one of
the winter olympicses
so it just means it has everything that
you need because all the athletes had to
stay there um while they were giving
each other rampant chlamydia
so
oh sick totally yeah just like koalas
but yeah it was it was beautiful like
really really
just like winter wonderland vibes and i
think more snow more snow it did snow
awesome i've made a decision
as a result of the boulder trip and also
whistler that i want to make sure that i
see snow at least once a year it just
makes like the seasons feel a bit
different when you live in california
and everything's [ __ ] same
it's summer for 11 months dude it's 27
degrees again next week let me find out
what that is in fahrenheit that's
[ __ ] that's all
i'm not gonna calculate it yeah
fahrenheit
i think i know that because in uh
[Music]
it is 80 dude it's 80.
one friday away 80 degrees
already
it's been so nice and cool for a while i
know it's just ramping up it looks like
it's snowing right now in kansas city
john when i was in it is well it was
earlier today uh when i was in korea it
was a steady 30 the entire time
when it was raining is it humid though
it was well that was the thing it was
like it was
[ __ ] humid so it wasn't even the heat
like 86 is fine but team it's bad with
the high humidity combined oh my god
because the thing about la heat
is that i don't feel like it's that
humid here mm-hmm metal actually it's so
it can be sometimes but it isn't a lot
but usually like the hot hot heat that
you get in like june here and then
weirdly like nice again in september is
not that hot in terms of sorry humidity
it's not that sweaty it's just like you
just said it was hot whereas
and i guess you go to vegas it's way
worse your eyes burn but if you're in
like louisiana or new york
you just are dripping in sweat it's
disgusting that's like every time we go
to rtx it would always be oh my god yeah
it'd be so hot and so humid yeah is it
like is it over july fourth weekend this
year again i don't know i didn't think
so i think they're bringing it i think
july 4th
they tear you away from your family yeah
wait who spends july 4th with their
family is that a thing he's doing a
[ __ ] had a smoker whoa look at that
oh my god are you okay
yeah
that's why i should be an actor
someone put their hands on mine and you
can see a vet i want to see the vagina
show me a [ __ ] show me a [ __ ]
that i've seen in his life
show me
i saw i saw uh this post that was so
disturbing that it was like
what if the vagina hole is actually has
a giant eye in it and men just don't
know because women take it out
right before sex every time why did you
see that
i think it was on uh oddly specific
subreddit is that post
or suspiciously specific who said that
oh wait is there validity
i can't comment um
i would just like to know like like like
like those just off the ass
oh there you go yeah yeah no we don't
have eyeballs up here take the eyeball
you know the [ __ ] and the lips are
both sphincters yeah uh so when you kiss
you're connect you're making a a trail
from one sphincter to another oh jacob
oh
this is one you have seven sphincters in
your body
seven
no wait mark yeah because like
throughout the digestive system yeah
that makes sense things that like
there's one between the small energy
testing
where are we chronologically we're up to
whatever john wants to tell us about i
believe
i'm back in l.a
you're backing up
yep oh yeah
how do i even begin go ahead
take us on a journey john
get a dm
it says shoot him a shot and i said
i'll check it out
you replied and said i'll check it out
yeah okay uh
well no i said that mentally
and then i followed them private account
turns out
[ __ ] hottie
this is so
that
the person
the person the person that i send you uh
pictures i'm in agreement context
hottie uh
so i said i'm shot
because they said they're shooting their
shots nice anyways we were dm'ing dm'ing
and then when i went to new orleans
i told my buds about them nice rubble
are those adidas slips
your slides where are they called
little nike boy
um when i went to new orleans they're
like because they're all you know
they're all day trippers like me
they're like flying out or like go go
you know go there because they're from
canada
uh
right rahul
anyways there's like three feet of snow
in toronto right now so i said i'll fly
you out
why the heck not
whoa whoa whoa whoa there's some
questions uh yeah we got i feel like
there's chronological issues with just
dms to fly out
okay i was like
[Music]
all right
it was fat gas did you yeah yeah
non-binary fairy with the bodice of a
goddess that's what i've been saying
well that's good oh that's nice um okay
so
you were instagram dm'd mm-hmm
randomly sorry john are we being
insensitive is this person actually
non-binary
yeah oh i apologize i assumed that you
were trying to be coy they don't care
okay still sorry
i didn't think anyone said anything to
retreat yeah i don't know i kept saying
oh come on why are you being so
offensive
i'm very sorry about that i own my
mistakes
i deserve
john what's their preferred pronouns
save him
right so you're on it let me back in
yeah go ahead
so you're just on instagram and you get
a a random dm and they said
what
i don't know they said what's up you're
hot
and then you saw my ticket
and that was why i actually responded
because you know i get a lot of
a lot of fans
yeah messaging me saying i want to bang
you yeah totally mostly bears
um
but yeah [ __ ] if they've known me for a
long time and they've been following me
i feel like it's like there's a power
dynamic thing i learned from pro jared
not gonna happen
good that's good that's good yeah yeah
so i i just wanna say you learn from but
then the message i got they're like hey
i saw a couple of your tick tocks
and i was like new fan
great gonna make sense i need i should
make a personal relationship before
they're actually like a
fan got it i said could you could you uh
go to work and and um jerk off in the
work toilets and send us pictures back
with all the ideas
i did my back works at my time right
over there
[Music]
jacobs jacob's meat drunk i love it
sorry could please continue i don't know
i mean yeah so then you messaged them
you messaged them back and and they said
they were from toronto so you said we'll
fly out to we video chatted a few times
so i made it oh that's a good bet they
were a real person
i'm not i'm not having that happen to me
you're not a [ __ ] dumbass
four [ __ ] gigabytes oh my god um so
anyway
well that's a gigantic [ __ ] jacob
jumps in you know drunk so fast
hello [ __ ] all right please okay yeah so
so you had a video chat yeah we have
videos
uh diligence good idea yeah in my like
so my buddies in new orleans were like
just fly out why not just [ __ ] take
it fly out
and so i was like yeah why not because
you're a day so
because i'm a day tripper day trooper i
i had a long distance relationship a
while ago and like
we met like a couple times in very
specific circumstances and then the
first three months was long distance
and then
i flew out to see them in new york
and literally the moment i get to union
station and see them i go this isn't
going to work
wow why
i don't know was it the appeal of being
distanced
i don't i don't know it it was just
i feel like being in person with people
and actually getting to know them is
different from life so your relationship
started distance
yes exactly like i met them at a at a
new year's party
and then they came out uh one time and
we hung out for like 12 hours
and then it became long distance so it
was only long distance pretty much
so then when i actually met them in
person i was like oh no
so i wanted to get yourself did you get
your dick wet though i did very much so
yeah um that's a good test new york baby
anything can happen that well vegas but
yep
yeah did you wait what happened to your
six days in new york did you have sex
before or after you said this isn't
gonna work
uh i said it with my eyes that sounds
like post-nut talk
[Laughter]
yeah it was good i don't wanna do this
yeah then i'm tired
so like what did you say when you're
when you should go home
that flight feels like that return
flight's a lot longer than that outgoing
one yeah
seriously not
um but anyways i wanted to prevent that
so i was like i want to meet this person
spend some actual time with them before
we're [ __ ] messaging yeah put you
about for a long time
so i flew him out
exhale are you aware that they could
listen to the podcast
uh oh hey nice name alana thank you i
appreciate that
i told them
that i'll probably be very honest and
they said i won't listen to it but
they're probably kind of in secret
yeah
yep well so what the [ __ ] are we doing
well it's fine he hasn't said anything
bad i know the thing is that it's it's
going to be i'm going to very well i'm
going to ask some very very invasive
questions ask me everything that's why
i've been drinking we've not identified
the person that privacy is secure
rahul
you've known
from this podcast and from outside of
the podcast
i am
unashamed i'm not ashamed of anything
that i've done i've spoken about
things that other people
would feel
so much shame over and they'd feel like
pathetic
losers yeah i don't feel that way no
not a loser
so so yeah so you spent some time video
chatting and then they flew out to
you there yeah they flew out we dropped
them
yeah what would you get up to sorry drop
their bags here orleans
no no no no they flew to kansas city
picked them up
dropped our bags off we went to dinner
at dinner
we're chatting
uh where'd you go eat
we went to a place called mickey's
hideaway
they had pokemon fries it was pretty
cool that's awesome
what's pokemon fries it's sweet potato
with kimchi and
some other [ __ ]
it was really good that sounds delicious
i know alana likes them
i know a lot of likes he says it just
about pokemon
oh it's a potato which shaped like a
turban i would love that it's fair i
would think that was it this guy's so
you know
from this podcast as well my history
with escorts that
i have an on-again-off-again
relationship
kind of a love-hate relationship with
escorts well that makes you sound like a
serial killer
i'm not so that's fine the only time
i've ever heard anyone say
like i have a love-hate relationship
with escorts is on a netflix documentary
yeah
well you know i have a love hate
relationship you gotta blur out john's
face and be like okay
they reveal
former escort and i say oh
oh hell yeah
and you said i have loved it related
former john
and you revealed a lot of canadian cash
yeah yeah i won't be back
her loonies are boonies
this is a this is a reason
a great thing to jump into is like so
that clearly didn't bother you
[ __ ] no to any of the rest of you do you
think it would bother you if you were
dating absolutely not only fans sex
workers yeah any of it no yeah i would
get right behind that like that's
awesome okay
absolutely says says the man who's
renamed himself boba fat [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
not a joke he did do that
yeah
i saw you you [ __ ] i'll change it mark
mark i'll change it if you need me to
i'll change it back oh god
so
everyone's consensus is known
who gives a [ __ ] okay so can i ask them
to
to talk about it like completely
honestly like is it something that say
you were dating somebody and they wanted
to start an only fans would it need to
be something you had a discussion about
would there be like limits
no i'd say let me go buy a new lens for
my camera no like yeah that's exactly
like i'd be involved like i'd go do the
same thing i'd be like your photographer
let me subscribe to photoshop so i can
make you look attractive so i can expand
those knocks
that's harsh in a different way
yeah i mean for the
jacob
so i can take out all those lumps yes
she's quite smart quite educated yes
but i've told her like hey if you like
that we've like just like hypotheticals
of course but i was like yeah and i'd be
like hell yeah i'd be your photographer
repeatedly
have you ever thought about only fans
yeah you'd be like hey have you ever
terry you ever thought about only fans
i keep i bring it up every week
hey remember last week when we were
talking about only fans we didn't talk
about it we're family we're family right
so we can say this about one another if
terror ever did only fans
first picture first picture
tastefully done like austin powers
nude terror drums
symbols coverings oh
i've brought that up i've brought that
out you've read my i love that when we
did the face dunks in the snow
you can see tara's boobs in hers
[Laughter]
okay but i love that you all say that
like i i have i think that that you can
respect people having different comfort
levels but i don't feel like that should
ever apply to what somebody else does as
a profession i think it just kind of
makes you yeah i feel like it's like the
only people it affects are people who
are insecure with their own yeah [ __ ]
imagine
how good it feels
knowing that some
one
is getting off to a picture of your
partner some men feel very differently
about that i'm sure women do too
i've dated guys who like if i got hit on
in public they'd be mad at me
they'd yell at me they'd be like oh yeah
well maybe if you weren't wearing those
[ __ ] shorts this wouldn't happen like
get really upset about it if you were
[ __ ] hot
come on
it's like folks who get mad at like
streamer like like woman streamers who
like stream it is one of the same don't
wear turtlenecks yeah yeah for a very
pro sex worker
stealing your audiences no you're just
[ __ ] boring that's the thing that
gets me about it nobody's stealing your
audience you're just [ __ ] boring only
i had titties they'd be watching me too
that's true of you jacob yeah
get your tits out
i say it every stream i do every time
i'm doing like a gun to building stream
like man i have such a bigger audience
in half i had big old orcs just died
dropping out in front of the camera
that's true it's true
i don't i don't get any of that like
yeah it's such a it's it's it's the
policing in such an insecure way
top level right like when i say top
level i mean like in terms of fate oh
sorry well russell you and i have
friends that's a real easy example you
roll say you would date you you and i
have friends who have bought houses from
only fans people who are very successful
that's badass what can you introduce me
i don't want to name them
it's bruce
i don't want to name them just in case
they wouldn't be comfortable for
whatever reason because i did ask one of
them to do a podcast before and she was
like i'm not really comfortable so i
don't want to
you know who that is i don't want to
flag
that but let's let's take it to like the
highest like i said to like the easiest
degree right
if say you were dating britney spears
at the height of her popularity in fame
not to say that she was a sex worker i'm
not saying that at all but a big part of
her product and a big part of her wide
appeal was obviously how attractive she
was or how sexy she was the same goes
for someone like hold on you said it the
height of popularity is it at the height
of her physical
you know
are they not one in the same probably
wait isn't that when she was in baby one
more time that's rude maybe one more
time like 16. yeah
she was underrated
yeah really
well i was like
we're sending that let's we're sending
that now real quick take it back back oh
daytrip are gone
um but salma hayek look think about
simon heights sam hayek's like
one of the most [ __ ] beautiful
people
ever stunning
mass appeal
if you were dating
and she had another film role
and in that film role she's playing a
character who
uh
getting railed every scene it's pawn
[ __ ] flaps in the wind yeah
yeah i mean this just is just eternal i
shouldn't say things like this because
at this point
at this point one day i could get
announced that i'm doing a film with
salman you're never gonna work on a
marvel film when you talk like this on
podcasts for a whole year
marvel this is why disney won't hire you
ah turtles had a sex scene did it what
they say to alana that's what they do to
me every fricking day
is mcu disney won't touch oh yeah what i
parodied though yeah go ahead
um um but again i'm not saying that's
like i'm not comparing that to sex work
obviously but
being but like being attractive or using
or or whatever the [ __ ] like that's so
isn't that envious i thought that was a
good thing i thought it was yeah like i
feel the same way that like being with
somebody who others desire
seems great um but i know that not all
again i think i've dated more people who
did not feel that way than people who
have felt that way grow a pair that's
what i say to him
yeah get your own that's what i say to
you yeah i've had um uh boyfriends who
would control what i wore
like exactly that's their own security
things like get mad at like so the one
there was one time where i
was the first time that i remember being
like
man this is [ __ ] up i was wearing a
skirt and i
basically like
sat down like like if you were to squat
but it's not like my legs were spread i
was just squatted just to like sit while
we were waiting for something or
something and he intentionally stood in
front of me and went
and i was like what he was like everyone
can see up your [ __ ] skirt because i
squat it
um in public because it was more
comfortable to do so while waiting for
something and i was like jesus this is
such a like a weirdly controlling thing
what i didn't ask him to stand in front
of me he just decided to do it [ __ ]
how
just incredibly like unhappy and
controlling about the idea that anybody
could look at me in any way that like
was deemed as his um and i regret not
saying something but that's the first
time that that dude had told me to wear
different things multiple times uh but
that was the first time i remember being
like this is maybe not fair maybe unfair
and it's it is really common and i think
it's like people
you're right that it's insecurity i
think it's insecurity tied to like
worrying that whoever is going to leave
them yeah i mean it's jealousy right
like
because i actually learned the
difference between envy and jealousy
envy is wanting something that people
have jealousy is fear of losing what you
have
so like yeah yeah so
yeah when you like you know when people
in relationships
see them flirting with other people
thinking that that's jealousy yeah it's
that's jealousy where they're like
they're gonna leave me for that person
so probably anyone being attracted to
your partner like what you have to be
jealous they were going through they are
jealous yeah that's jealous that's
driven by jealousy a fear of of loss
that's interesting
it's a very i'm sure i'm
i'm sure this doesn't well were you
gonna say boba fett [ __ ] what was good
how much meat did you drink sweet baby
boy did you eat lunch or dinner yeah can
someone text tara to [ __ ] come in and
make sure he's all right i had this
coming with the drums nude
symbols
i said i'm just saying it's it's just
inside like i did say that we might do a
dnd show
on patreon if if you guys are all
interested and i was going to ask tara
to be a part of that because she wanted
to stop stop
shut your bed [ __ ] mouth you just
reminded me of something you shut your
[ __ ] mouth
steamforged games just reached out to my
agent
no i'm joking they saw that we bought
that dark souls uh
so so subscribe to the patreon yeah yeah
so st so steam forge also make
um the the miniature board game which we
didn't buy which i always wanted you
know you paint the miniatures and you
played
games yeah but
the reason they also reached out to me
is because they're really it's on
pre-order now it's about to come out
it's the [ __ ] d and d dark souls so
it's the book with the thing and then
you play as a group so if we're going to
do d and d considering jacob
i'm an incredible dm just ask jacob yeah
ranger it'll be amazing i'll contact
them and i'll let them know and i'll
also tell them [ __ ] it i'll be like hey
we were looking to do something anyway
so whatever don't say that say if you
sponsor us
we might be inclined exactly we get a
lot of views on that
yeah but i have free miniatures
okay not a team player got it
there okay i can buy it rather than do
your thing
what do you have those minis jacob
what are you holding
these
[Laughter]
that's right lana you taught me what
clackers are yeah it's a clanger a
clanger i thought clacka was like a
butthole or something but yeah if we're
looking for if we're looking for a dnd
game that's the
that's that that seems like a production
meeting we can have later as a yeah as a
team
have a catch
you know jacob's getting drunk when he
starts squinting i know it's funny
as soon as he stops there's that picture
i have oh god big bear where he's doing
this is the american
i don't know if you have a squint john
i don't think i'm aware of it
it's coitus
so speaking of coitus how was it yes
where are we okay so as as we were
driving back i was like you know because
i know all about escorts yeah uh i was
like so uh like did you did you offer
like the girlfriend experience because i
always thought that's funny the because
it's not even it's less about sex and
more about the companionship
yeah and they're like oh yeah i did
girlfriend experience i also did porn
star experience and i was like
what
yeah um
so
i think i got a mix
okay
uh
yeah but i mean it was uh no no no no no
no what does that mean well slow down a
little bit what does the porn star
experience mean
i don't know but i think i might have
experienced you got a bit of both
well hold on were you
this entire
meeting jacob just deep throated the
fiddle city i missed that i missed that
[ __ ] hell
off he's getting away from
jesus
john
are you guys dating yeah
congrats
yeah that's awesome dude yeah can we
meet them yeah are you sure you're
dating
do they know you're dating sure here's
the thing
and this is where maybe they're
listening maybe they're not um
they are in an open relationship
um
but since you are too
but
uh
they have gone polly
because i
turns out
can't just be a fling with me oh
yeah that's really cute there are so
many words there that's right if that it
would have blown ben shapiro's mind
congrats dude not just his mind so
basically uh
polyamorous
yeah what does that mean
it means uh so open means that you have
a primary partner but you guys can have
flings and casual hookups with other
people poly is where you have
uh like intimate relationships with
multiple people
oh okay yeah yeah so came out
they came out they're like this is just
me a fling
when they left they're like
are we gonna move in together and like
have a bunch of kids and i was like slow
it down
direct back in
do you think that they would come on the
podcast with the anonymous
uh voice mod and a public screen and we
can ask sex work questions oh yeah we
had a great time together
and then i joked that i sent uh
their nudes uh and they
they believe they're like oh yeah great
do they know who we are are they a
little bit starstruck that you're
friends with us
by that you mean you rahul you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] yeah they weren't they
watching
jacob
oh did they oh they know me from oh that
stream
[Laughter]
no they actually
like that was the interesting thing and
that was why i felt more comfortable
getting to know them is that
they are
uh in
not like directly but they're so they we
have like mutual connections
industry-wise and stuff so
yeah it wasn't like that's definitely a
point that i am at where i don't think i
could date anyone that isn't in some way
associated with my life it's too scary
like it has to be somebody who knows
somebody or is like i've never dated
anyone in the games industry i don't
know that i would want to do that but
like somebody who at least is like
related to my life yeah i don't want to
take a [ __ ] nerd
and after that
perish
but congrats
if i'm going to date someone they're
going to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
100 [ __ ] that's what i feel that's what
tara told me yeah porn star experience
what line is from you today jacob
he just sneaks him in he just drops him
in there
what's [ __ ] going on
hell it's me
[Applause]
because i when i flew to new orleans and
then when i flew
uh my friend out
uh i was like
when am i gonna go to la and hang out
with my homies again so i miss you i
texted you guys today i i will have
elden ring early i don't know when but
i'm i would love to record some let's
plays
oh hell yeah i am not a part of any of
those unless you can come back if you
can rahul then totally but like i don't
do a lot of let's play series
sit down jacob's leaving
i don't do a lot of let's play series is
where i record multiple episodes of
things anymore but i was like i do it
for elden ring if i can get you guys to
come and we could sit down and just like
play a ton of it and i could just do
like hour long
so i think we could probably make that
happen this month i get to see john soon
do you guys want to come out to
vancouver i can't travel yes please
i would love to do it well i don't know
i don't want to get killed by a nazi
yeah we didn't even talk about that so
there was a freedom
well it's it's still happening yes and i
actually found some more information
about it today um from a goalie lives in
ottawa
hold on before we move off of my
re losing my virginity again yes
because you know your vision oh you
haven't had sex in like four years
okay hold on um how quick did you come
not that quick at all my friend haley
did you have to like game that though
i was afraid of that
no no no no it's fine what you call it
speaking it's fine
i i've learned that when whenever we if
there's nothing if it's uh
like when i was with the prostitute
sorry escort full sex worker ladies and
gentlemen sex worker
and massage parlors
instant
okay but
when it's an actual hookup
it's maybe i'll last too long
some say too long
but here's another here's the thing i
learned
um it's because you're thinking about
them just as effective as condoms did
you guys know that what is it it's more
effective yeah pulling out is just as
effective as condoms
so for everyone listening ps4 um
throw your condoms hang on just give me
a sec you can finish finish whatever you
were saying
uh so what i was saying that's great
what is this what he was saying was was
that pulling out is more effective um
hang on [ __ ] he just finished the whole
sentence before right now
you don't need condoms they just okay
um don't get or share cds
listen uh they're an escorts or they
were an escort so that they i'm not i
wasn't going through all of the problems
loops
all you got to do is get an abortion i
know yeah exactly
i learned that in canada it's hard not
to get an abortion
it's hard not to thank you you're
walking down the street
it's on to avoid
no
no you're curious
safe sex please everybody we are we
support safe sex glad that you had a
good amount of time well we're not
saying it doesn't feel good wrong um
congratulations can we meet them i would
like to i would love to what did jacob
just say what did you just say
i want to answer someone talking about
loving it loving raw dog in it
do we get to meet
you
wait jacob are you saying are you saying
you like being pegged raw is that what
you're saying i mean i'm not gonna
offer any specifications at this point i
said what i said
all right everyone on the internet is
convinced i like peggy i've never done
it huh you've been pegged don't knock it
till you try it you haven't been picked
no no no i have a peg that's hard to
believe what about like
that
what about like pre-bidet before you had
a bidet you get pegged by your bidet and
your thumb goes through your toilet
paper on accident
oh yeah yeah wait a second hold on
rahul
yeah
i don't want to put you on blast here
but
i talked about how
i use the uh
tushy
little bamboo cloth that they give us
let's talk about jacob knows about this
yeah so i mentioned that to you and you
started making fun of me
because you said that i get poo on it
what are you doing and i said no
i use my so when you get a tushy i have
two tissues
did it come with those little bamboo
like
no no
we have our own brand bamboo wipes
yeah
so they're basically little washcloths
um with the concept is the whole point
of a day
is that you save paper you don't use
toilet paper it's just a little bit um
yes well here's the thing
i don't know about you know the you you
hairless porpoise
alana thank you but for us men
hello big hairy man if your ass is wet
and you put toilet paper down there it's
dingleberry city i don't have that
problem
you don't know what rahul do you shave
your ass
yeah
i stopped before also
are you just spritzing yourself like i
turn it on and i you know i get the hips
no no no no no no yeah yeah yeah the
hips a little bit yeah yeah you get a
little circle motion yeah
i blast it and and i i love a little bit
and i get in it quite a while okay most
of twitter
and instagram
i like it a lot
but
what you're talking about is drying
right
now because if i thought that the bidet
removed all [ __ ]
no matter how long you bidet for you
still need a little little wipe you
can't just then
all right next time do me a favor then
yeah
if you believe in that so much
i want you before your uh new mrs
mm-hmm
what's a non-binary word for mrs mr
sister
mr sister
hey guys just got another cover test uh
just one of those nice oh i got one of
those today too
before your new mr sister
comes round
i want you to have a fat [ __ ]
right i want you to bidet and do all the
things you do then i want you to go over
and grab their pillowcase and dry your
ass with it if you're that [ __ ]
confident
and then continue with the rest of your
if they get a big guy
is that the gamble we're doing right now
i just want to see if he's that
confident that the bidet removes 100
[ __ ] do it on their pillowcase well are
you using like eight ply toilet paper or
something
oh okay because like the toilet paper i
use the moment it touches water it
breaks down so i make sure i buy the the
thicker more durable it can't all be
hollywood's mr hollywood's though
exactly hollywood beverly to be honest i
just do it on an ads hand i just get an
ad or a tab to come in or that's how you
do it
like give me your [ __ ] hand and i and
i get it
in your home country there is no bidet
there's just a bucket of water on the
left-hand side of the england [ __ ] are
you talking about in india
oh india
my brother went to india it's not his
home who said who said i'm from [ __ ]
india
i see you i see what you look like
where am i from
east side bruv oh
oh no john pictures god what country was
i born in what country was i born in
bangladesh i don't [ __ ] know
oh no i want everyone on this podcast to
know he doesn't have my consent to make
these types of jokes i'm deeply
uncomfortable don't need him london
boris he's a london boy and he's so
bloody lit
where's my mom from what country is my
mom born in i know the answers
pakistan
thailand thailand
where's my dad born
philippines
chicago
i think elon is
lip sync uh lipping a a slur yeah what
are you saying alana i was saying kenya
yeah my dad's from africa really wakanda
forever
i have a cousin who uh is the son of an
african king that's cool
his name is dapo
he's dope
your cousin is is an african prince yes
i am not joking how
i don't know the specifics but uh his
dad his dad left africa moved to london
uh met
his wife
and then had dappo and dappo was just
like chills dabo is a pretty sick name
right
watch jacob is joking
[Laughter]
were you deep throating that fiddle
stick again no i'll tell the story later
but like we filmed a video recently
where i was choking on coke and pepsi at
the same time and the worst noises that
have ever come out of a human
came out of my throat
okay so
chronologically chronologically yeah
boba fett
pretty far through the podcast at this
point i've got the main character of
boba fett
um we are about to talk about book of
birth uh thank you for watching
everybody this is an extra long episode
um we will have more exclusive content
up on patreon this month i have a fun
game for us to play the vlog is already
up if you've missed it thank you to
everybody for supporting we appreciate
you
and uh we will see you all
next time which is the first monday of
every month
yes stop asking me march 7th we know
what it is first monday of every month
we'll see you then also remember don't
wear a rubber wear a rubber
[Music]
[Music]
you